hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the
adventures of meek and morphine I really
enjoyed your jokes in the previous video
that pickle Rick one was a not be
correct pickle meek was that was a was a
very nice touch but yeah now we're
continuing with the match Morpheus
currently leading the match two to zero
and he only needs one more winter at
well ended the match if not we're still
gonna see at least three games if morphe
doesn't achieve a victory here so
without further ado let's check it out
eva is already on the board so II for
now with a five by morphine 9 f3 Knight
to c6 and in third game judge meek goes
for the Scotch opening we have d4 sorry
about that immediately striking in the
center more fee no stranger to the
Scotch himself eek after Sun before and
now c3 I well-known gambit the Guren
gambit so the so-called Guren gambit
we've captured in c3 and mountain Knight
captures on c3 more if you often enjoyed
even going further with the gamble with
Bishop to c4 offering the B to point as
well but here meek is satisfied with the
development he's got Knight captures on
c3 with push up to c5 my morphine and
Bishop to c4 both players continuing
development we have d6 and now at h3 not
allowing more fetus Bishop to g4 idea
although might be that th to remove
isn't all that necessary perhaps if you
just Castle it's a Bishop g4 you can
unpin with with Queen to b3 as it comes
with an attack on the b7 and the D f7
pawn so also also possibility but it is
quite complicated you have to consider
this you have to consider Knight a5 for
example attacking the Queen and the
bishop a Queen d7 just defending so a
lot of ideas here so instead a me just
that prevents Morphy from going to g4
and Bishop to e6 now again more if you
wants the trade here to get the semi
open F file for his rook and it's a very
important to know that this position has
never been reached again Bishop to b5
now which is kind of a loss of a temple
now as you already played Bishop to c4
and now you're moving it back to b5 and
you're allowing Morpheus excellent
square for his bishop
so usually it will just keep it there
maybe just defend it maybe go goes back
to b3 or Queen e2 or something like that
or or even just capture but Bishop to b5
not so much but okay 97 by morphine and
now Knight to g5 being down to two
points in the match probably makes meek
would want to just go for it and it is
one game where he really goes for it so
Knight g5 we have castles and now Queen
to h5 already threatening mate which
isn't all that big of a deal since
there's only one move a one good move
for black that defends mate and that is
h6 this is what Morphy plays and now
Knight back to f3 as the night is under
attack you could try something like h4 I
just defend the night there but more if
you will just ignore you and he's gonna
continue to get sound like a sex potion
to put the dash back and continue the
game he's not gonna bother with your
knight and g5 but okay me goes back
Knight of three and now Knight to g6
trying to get the knife to f4 that to
further her as the Queen not at the
moment because the bishop is guarding it
but he does have plans of doing so
g4 by meek like I said Mickey's going
all out this game and now Knight ct5 an
excellent square for the knight and also
if characters which is what happened in
the game now comes D captures an e5 and
now the f4 square is guarded for for the
Knights to occupy and now g5 look at
Nick Nick is unstoppable here he wants
to he wants to checkmate morphine and he
is you know not not even trying to be
secretive about it but Queen to b4 now
it's more fickle threatens mate Bishop
to e3 walking mate and attacking the
Queen now Queen to b4 and here me goes
for Bishop captures in c5 now attacks
the Queen and the bishop but Morphy
could capture the bishop but he could
also go for the B to pawn capturing the
bishop really allows me to go forward
with the attack but if you calculate
precisely for example captures on h6 9f
for pushes the Queen back Queen g5
threatens mate g6 defending mate Queen
to f6 now again threatening me
Knight h5 defends mate end kicks away
the Queen Queen g5 King h7 and Morphy
would continue to play this with a
better position as the black king is
very safe there and the white king
doesn't really know where he's gonna go
to the King say the Queen side and it's
not very safe in the center of the board
so Queen captures and c5 worse for more
fee but he he prefers the this time he
was for the more complicated Queen
captures and b2 and now again he's
attacking the rook he's attacking the
knight and he's asking me what do you
want to do with best defense and meet
actually gets to keep the exchange but
he will be down a lot of points and this
is what me chooses it is the strongest
move recommended by the engine so good
for me he castles here he gives up the
night
now the rooks are defending each other
Queen captures on c3 and he goes for the
exchange Bishop captures on f8 we rock
out for Santa f8 and now it's a it's a
it's a pretty tricky position meek is up
the exchange but Morphy is up well for
the moment up to pawns and but white
points are very weak so here you could
just continue with G characters on h6
night at 4 and so on but first rook 8 2
c1 meek once the well further develop
his forces before committing to the
final attack Queen to b2 by morphine now
attacking the bishop here and me goes
Bishop to c4 he wants to now well either
capture here which will remove the
defender of the night or he trades and
then he just well it eliminates one of
the attackers of the h3 pawn but here's
a problem or if he has Knight to f4 and
now the problem is that the pawn is now
attacked twice so meek has to go back
Queen back to d1 and the night captures
on h3 width check we have King back to
g2 tonight the f4 width track and King
to h1 and here we have Queen to b6 and
this is a very very important move for
several reasons which you'll see in the
game so here best for meek is to maybe
try and trade Queens and play the same
game even though he's down a lot of
pawns for example capture some g5 queen
capture some b6 you're gonna capture
and now you try and play this endgame
where meat is down four points here's up
the exchange so maybe he could maybe he
could pull through but it's very
unlikely
so instead me goes for G captures on h6
but now you are playing Morphy here i
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for white for for
morphe who is black obviously well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
Queen to Bishop who was played to
control the sixth rank and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
special characters on c4 you just grab a
piece and now if if the piece is
recaptured with real characters in c4
and then it's checkmate in for Queen
captures on h6 check Kings you want now
Queen g5 with checking h1 and Queen to
g2 will be made so nothing you can do
about that
so instead Mick tried one last idea
h7 width Trek King captures on h7 and
now Queen g4 not allowing this check
fall by Queen g5 check as the Queen now
covers g5 but still more figures Quinta
h6 with check King to g1 and now just
picks up the rook Bishop captures on f1
and here okay Mick didn't get checkmated
but he's down too much material rook
captures on f1 and here just worked the
d8 more fees up a piece and there's not
much to do here meat plate a few more
moves
a4 but Murphy plate of course the
strongest move rook to d6 the rook is
coming to g6 and that's that's it
there's there's no way to save the the
Queen or the game so f3 was played
trying to make a run for it with the
king but more features playbook to g6
and well that's just it although MIG
didn't resign here meek played King to
f2 and then he resigned which is a bit
odd in game 1 and game 3 I think in game
2 also mix last move was not something
you would usually play I mean you resign
you don't play like weird moving then
resign it this looks to me like it was
played in in mean maybe 2020 in modern
chess and then you know someone picks up
the King and places it and then the the
electronic board remembers
and then the PG&E generated that way
that's what this move reminds me of but
no it's actually what meek played and it
was only in this position on move 31
that he resigned the game so really
impressive stuff by Murphy Murphy beats
both of the opponents he played so far
with a result of 3 to 0 but Paulson who
defeated his first opponent 3 to 0 also
defeated Montgomery his second opponent
also 3 to 0 even though only two games
were played and a third game was won by
default as Montgomery had to return to
Philadelphia
so Murphy and Paulson doing really well
next next up are the semi-finals of the
first American chess congress so we're
gonna see what happens there and after
defeating judge meek Alexander baffled
meek he made a joke that was apparently
very funny he said that Murphy should
really give him an opportunity here and
there like he shouldn't play the
strongest moves all the time because if
he continues doing so that meek will
pick him up put him in his pocket and
carry him away now either either humor
really changed in the last 150 years or
maybe I just don't get the joke but
supposedly the the joke is is somewhat
funny I guess
because Murphy was a very tiny person in
Georgia meek was quite a large person
and then it was funny because it's not
hard to imagine judge meek actually
picking up Murphy and putting him in his
pocket
due to the well just the difference in
their size I guess however there may be
there's also something else that just
isn't funny after 150 years but you know
in the spirit of the moment yeah I guess
it could be somewhat funny so yeah now
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
more if he takes the second match with
the result of 3 to 0 and well we'll just
have to see what happens next I would
like to thank Abdullah Roger boiler
Kevin Stephen white Benjamin Schultz's
and Vlad Seminole for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos serum thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga are checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an
the rest of your day